we have a constantly growing population
this means that we will need fifty to
seventy percent more food by 2050 so
where are we going to find 50 to 70
percent more food in only 30 years
natures are ready building and
sustaining all life on Earth we don't
have to reinvent the wheel the calories
we need and we eat and we have take from
food comes from the sand
the starting point for all food on earth
is photosynthesis sunlight combines with
carbon dioxide and water in plants and
forms oxygen and glucose this sugar is
stored in fruits fruits and vegetables
one startup in London thinks harnessing
photosynthesis in microscopic plants
could go some way to solving our planets
imminent food crisis we have to start
with microalgae strain they are the
fastest-growing photosynthesizing
organism on this planet these very tiny
microscopic plants contain hundreds and
hundreds of very precious healthy food
molecules that can be extracted and
utilized in our own food microalgae x'
aren't on many menus yet but they might
be the new super foods packed full of
vitamins antioxidants and minerals they
sustain trillions of animals on our
planet our boria claims it's technology
the bio solar leaf helps grow this food
at rates rarely seen in nature our borås
by solar leaf looks like similar to AB
solar panel a technology that can
produce and can grow hundreds of
different microscopic plants to produce
hundreds of different ingredients it
enables to grow them very quickly but
also in a very efficient way therefore
consuming very little amount of energy
we can produce a lot of protein in a
very small surface area so imagine that
we can produce more protein for a
defined surface area than any other
plant-based or animal based source on
this planet by orders of magnitude we
harvest some of this liquid we separate
the liquid from the microalgae and then
we dry it and usually it's either in a
flake form or in a powder form ready to
be shaped to food producers so that they
can utilize them in all sorts of food
products that they want
our boria imagines their food being used
as a supplement or being sold on its own
in stores there are hundreds of
thousands of species of microalgae all
with different qualities flavors and
even colors something that could be
interesting to food producers what we
can do with this ingredients that we
extract from from this microalgae
is that we can utilize them for all
sorts of processed food it's not only
replacing a synthetic or unsustainable
food ingredients but it's also adding
health benefits active health benefits
to our processed food let's say that we
have our Boris Big Blue together with a
yogurt this yogurt might contain more
antioxidant than you find in an Apple
originally Blue was associated with
something synthetic something unhealthy
right maybe blue is going to become the
new color associated with health why not
our boria's powdered food might not look
all that appetizing but their intention
is substance over style feeding our
growing population with the right things
in a better way might improve our
chances of future food security I
strongly believe that if we as human can
harness photosynthesis then we have high
chances to help solve the issues that we
are facing today and that we will face
in the future
[Music]
you